So, jetzt muss ich die richtige Auflösung haben.
Auf Twitch krieg dich ein und starte das Teil.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's, muss ich mal gucken, ob ich die richtige Auflösung hab.
Ja, jetzt hat's 1080p.
So, wunderbar.
Also, ist jetzt eine spontane Sache.
Ich wollte mir grad das neue Ubuntu angucken.
Also, das, was quasi in einem Monat rauskommt.
17.10
Und das kommt zum ersten Mal mit einem neuen Display-Server raus.
Und ich dachte mir, ich probier das mal auf.
Und ich hab grad auf Twitter gefragt, ob ich das streamen soll.
Und da haben überraschend viele Leute geschrieben, ja.
Hab ich mir gedacht, dann streamen wir das jetzt.
Vielleicht ein bisschen unglückliche Zeit, 14.40, Montags.
Da werden noch einige Leute auf der Arbeit sein.
Ja.
Aber gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es relativ schnell vorbei ist, weil, wie gesagt,
das ist noch ein Monat hin, bis das rauskommt.
Und vielleicht ist das Daily-Build so verbuggt, dass wir sie überhaupt nicht installiert bekommen.
0.3D
Moin, Filna.
Und auch das Imperatorchen.
Rox, Twitch-Mason, SilentPain, Alex, lieb Kekse und X-Fatal.
Tatsache.
Gut.
Fangen wir mal an.
Ich bin ja begeistert, wie viele Leute schon da sind um 14, um 14.40, Montags.
Lull.
So, also wir fangen mal an.
Also nochmal zur Erklärung, vielleicht für die, die gerade eingeschaltet haben.
Hallo, Evoli.
Wir gucken uns mal das neue Ubuntu an, was in einem Monat rauskommt.
Und wie so der neue Display-Server ist.
Also traditionell ist es ja so, dass Linux mit XORG läuft.
Also spricht für die grafische Oberfläche.
Ich meine damit nicht den Desktop an sich oder hier irgendwie Fenster rumschieben oder so,
auch wenn das jetzt Windows ist, sondern quasi so die Schnittstelle zwischen,
sagen wir es mal ganz grob, zwischen Grafikkartentreiber und Desktop.
Ich glaube das betrifft es eigentlich ganz gut, was ein Display-Server ist.
Und standardmäßig verwendet Linux schon seit einer ganzen Weile XORG
und jetzt der neueste Schrei ist allerdings Wayland.
Und Ubuntu beziehungsweise Canonical, die Hersteller von Ubuntu,
waren der Meinung, sie machen da nicht mit und bauen irgendwas eigenes.
Und glücklicherweise, ich glaube die Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
Machen wir mal ihn hier ein bisschen leiser.
Und jetzt mit dem neuen Ubuntu, was in einem Monat rauskommt,
hat sich allerdings Canonical auch dazu entschlossen,
sie scheißen auf, wir machen was eigenes, sondern nehmen Wayland.
Ubuntu die ganze Zeit haben die an mir rumgebaut,
das ist so eine eigene Sache gewesen von Ubuntu,
allerdings jetzt haben sie gesagt, okay wir nehmen das, was alle anderen auch nehmen,
wir nehmen Wayland.
Und Ubuntu 17.10 ist die erste Version, die quasi jetzt mit Wayland rauskommt
und mit nicht mehr diesem komischen Unity-Desktop.
Mit Unity ist in dem Fall nicht die Game Engine gemeint,
sondern Ubuntu Unity, der hässlichste Desktop aller Zeiten.
Ich kriege Augenkrebs, wenn ich das sehe. Guck dich das mal an.
Das ist so Instant-Kotz-Reflex, wenn ich Unity sehe.
Also, den Desktop. Bei der Engine kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten,
aber der Unity-Desktop sieht wirklich kacke aus.
Und jetzt ist Ubuntu für 17.10 auch umgeschwenkt auf,
übrigens hier Patrick, die Farbgebung ist immer noch die gleiche unter 17.10,
allerdings ist es dann unter dem neuen Ubuntu,
ist es wie gesagt Wayland als Display-Server und Gnome 3 als Desktop,
allerdings wieder mit dieser tollen Ubuntu-Farbgebung.
Dann müssen wir den ganzen Cramper jetzt mal runterladen.
Gibt's das denn? Daily. Daily-Build. Aktuell in Ubuntu.
Wohlgemerkt, Ubuntu 17.10 Release.
Das dauert noch ein bisschen, bis das offiziell rauskommt,
also das ist noch für Ubuntu-Verhältnisse so ziemlich früh in der Entwicklung.
Am 31. August gab's die Beta 1, in ein paar Tagen gibt's die letzte Beta-Version
und erst quasi ungefähr in vier Wochen kommt dann das finale Ubuntu 17.10 raus.
Also das ist für Ubuntu noch relativ früh und es kann sein, dass das jetzt überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Was? Why Lul and not Lul?
Ich wusste gar nicht mehr, dass man sich zwischen Lul und Lul noch entscheidet.
Ich dachte es geht eher darum, ob Lul oder Lul.
Also sprich ob Lul oder mit kleinem L.
Wobei ich ja der Meinung bin, dass Lul größer Lul ist.
Genau so wie es Alex gerade schreibt.
Hat es gerade geklingelt? Nee, oder?
So, laden wir uns mal das aktuelle Ubuntu Desktop runter,
also sprich das ist jetzt mit Wayland und Gnome 3.
Oh, das ist ja höchst, höchst, höchst Highspeed hier.
Na geht doch. Hat nur eine Weile gedauert, bis es anfängt.
So, da können wir schon mal OBS minimieren.
Hat es wieder geklingelt? Moment.
Hört ihr es klingeln? Hat es geklingelt? Ich höre das nämlich nicht mit meinem Headset auf.
Hat ihr das irgendwie gehört, ob es geklingelt hat?
Hat es gerade so angehört?
Na ja, in der Zeit, wo das runter lädt, können wir schon mal unsere VM anlegen.
So, habe ich hier natürlich auf Streaming-Account auch nichts angelegt bisher.
Ich habe fast gehört, du bist doch gerade auf der Arbeit, du dürftest eigentlich gar nichts hören.
Stimmt, stimmt, guck mal, warum habe ich denn überhaupt noch die Battlefield 1 Open-Picture?
Ich habe doch Battlefield 1 gar nicht.
Oder hat mir das EA gesponsert irgendwann mal?
Keine Ahnung, ich dachte, ich habe Battlefield 1 gar nicht, aber ich habe die Battlefield 1 Open-Picture.
Es geht in Closed-Speed-Sound, was auch sonst alles, warum ich es noch installiert habe, keine Ahnung.
Sgt. Sackfalte, das Sway ist quasi E3, richtig, deswegen will ich das auch ausprobieren.
Allerdings für Wayland, E3 hat keine Ambition, haben sie gesagt, Wayland zu supporten.
Und nachdem ich ja E3-Fan bin, bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig, in Zukunft wahrscheinlich Sway zu verwenden.
So, legen wir mal unsere VM an.
Installerdisk, das können wir nachher erst auswählen, wenn es runtergeladen ist.
Wir wollen Ubuntu 64 Bit, eigentlich wollen wir alles default haben.
Wie viel Festplattenplatz haben wir noch? Mal gucken.
Ja, es reicht.
2TB SSD, wisst ihr, wie Schweine teuer der Scheiß gewesen ist?
Wisst ihr, wie scheiße teuer eine 2TB SSD ist?
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mich da geritten hat, sowas zu kaufen.
Machen wir mal so, zwei Kerne.
Nicht 84, 2048, 2GB RAM zum Testen sollten ausreichen.
Alternativ, wir können auch, wie viel habe ich denn hier eigentlich drinne?
Null, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie viel RAM ich habe, 16, okay.
Ah, komm, dann gehen wir dem 4096.
Nicht das, was wir brauchen würden.
Bridge Network ist okay.
Wir wollen uns da per SSH drauf verbinden können.
Und das funktioniert hier mit Natnichtgescheit.
Not available.
Wir nehmen, wir nehmen das, we comment, gut.
Einfach alles default, create new disk.
Alles in einem Disk-File, machen wir mal, machen wir mal 30GB.
Man kann nie, nie genug Speicher haben.
Finish.
Gut, der Download ist auch fertig.
Dann hängen wir mal das neue Ubuntu da dran.
Download.
Artful.
Bringst der Name wieder geil?
Neue Ubuntu heißt, wo steht es denn überhaupt?
Ah ja, Artful, Artvark, falls man das so ausspricht.
Ich vermute mal, dass sie jetzt einfach wieder bei A anfangen.
Nachdem sie ja mit 1704 bei Z quasi aufgehört haben.
Was ziemlich unkreativ ist, muss ich mal ehrlich sagen.
Ich dachte, die lassen sich jetzt da vielleicht mal irgendwie eine lustigere Benamung einfallen.
So, Installer, ausgesagt, anmachen, gucken wir mal.
So, ich mach das mal groß.
Was will er von mir?
Ich will nicht ein- und auslocken.
Und nein, der soll auch nicht mein Mikrofon crappen.
Weil wenn er mal ein Mikrofon crabt, dann hört er mich nicht mehr.
Sound machen wir aus, brauchen wir nicht.
Außer doofes Geklingeln unter Knochen bringt uns das ja eh nix.
Wir haben schon fertig installiert.
So, machen wir das mal groß, dass man das ordentlich sieht.
Wobei, bei der Installation wird man, denke ich, eh nicht so viel sehen.
Es ist halt alles noch sehr, sehr, sehr beengt hier.
Was ist das? Okay, es ruckelt schon mal.
Install. Moins, Gary, Leggy.
Vier Terabyte SSD, RAID 10.
Das Witzige daran ist wahrscheinlich, dass das RAID 10 langsamer ist als eine einzelne SSD.
Jetzt nicht sequenziell oder so, aber zu Christsein.
Ja, können wir nachher machen, Continuum.
Bisschen größer könnten sie die Standardauflösung auch machen.
Install, ja passt alles.
Lautstärke, okay. Von Geklimper zu Voice.
Wir sind in Berlin, das ist auch richtig.
Tastatur wollen wir, German Layout.
Ich lasse zwar, ich installiere alle meine Software mittlerweile auf Englisch.
Das Einzige, was ich mache, ich stelle immer auf deutsche Tastatur Layout um.
Du hast einen QuietComfort 35 an. Das Ding habe ich mir auch gekauft letztens.
Das ist richtig gut, noise canceling, beste.
Test, Testwirtel, Maschinen, das Ding auch heißen.
Ultrasicheres Passwort hier, ihr könnt es kaum erraten.
Oh mein Battlefield 3-Server-Spam von BOTS sollte ich vielleicht mal ausschalten.
Ext, gut.
Was wusstest du das, was ich über LUL geschrieben habe gerade?
Was hast du denn über LUL geschrieben? Zeig mal.
Das weiß ich, das habe ich doch sogar letztens erzählt im Stream.
Das habe ich doch sogar letztens im Stream erzählt, dass das LUL da ist,
dass die das nachgemalt haben, das LUL, weil der Fotograf gemeckert hat,
der ihn fotografiert hat, was total beschränkt ist eigentlich,
dass es überhaupt geht. Aber ich meine Copyright, LUL.
Das versteht eh keiner.
Das heißt jetzt, wenn quasi irgendeiner mich in einer Aufnahme fotografiert,
wo sonst nichts drauf ist, dann habe ich nicht automatisch die Rechte,
weil da meine Fresse drauf ist, ne, sondern der Typ, der es fotografiert hat.
Ja, Tools installieren wir gleich.
Das Fenster gar nicht mehr moveen hier. Auch okay, dann move ich halt nicht das Fenster.
Hier oben darf ich aber noch klicken.
Da machen wir jetzt nichts, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal installieren.
Darf ich hier klicken? Oh, jetzt können wir uns den tollen Ubuntu Installer angucken.
Die Bilder hier überhaupt aktuell sind, sieht eher aus, als haben sie das vor 5 Ubuntu Versionen mal einen Screenshot vongenommen.
Jetzt, in dem Installer fehlt eigentlich bloß noch, Ubuntu 17.10 ist das beste Ubuntu, das es je gab.
So wie das früher bei Windows-Versionen immer gewesen ist.
War das gestern, wo ich das erzählt habe? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ja, ja, ja, ne, vorgestern war das.
Vorgestern war das.
Ich hab das jetzt übrigens mal in Kategorie Creative Programming gemacht, weil das der Sache noch am nächsten kommt.
Was anderes gibt es nicht, hoffentlich was passt.
Ich bringe mal nebenbei meinen Bot bei, dass der nicht mehr meinen Battlefield-Server spammen soll, während Ubuntu installiert.
Installation ist complete, super.
Kann schon mal neu starten.
Jede Ubuntu-Version, die ich bisher getestet habe, jede Beta-Ubuntu-Version hat es übrigens nicht geschafft, lustigerweise nach der Beta schon, aber die machen es in der Beta immer kaputt, dass sich VMS ordentlich neu starten.
Nach Installation.
Sieht wieder so aus, als hängt es jetzt.
Weiß nicht, was die haben immer.
So, jetzt machen wir hier nochmal Server Disable, dann spamt er nicht mal alle 10 Minuten meinen Battlefield-Server.
Na, das ist es, es hängt wieder, ist so geil.
Connected Power On brauchen wir nicht.
Wir schalten es wieder aus und halten es wieder an.
Hopp, zack.
Und jetzt gucken wir uns das neue Ubuntu mal an.
Das nervt nicht, ich will das nicht ändern.
Und das will ich auch nicht, weil Mikrofon connecten.
Ah, das sieht so aus, als wow.
Ah ja, okay.
Scheint was zu machen.
Wir müssen natürlich gleich noch Veränder-Tools installieren, dass wir Fullscreen kriegen.
So, auf das Passwort kommt...
Boah, was ist das für ein Input-Lag?
Alter, das ist ja nicht normal.
Hallo?
Komm, pass mal auf, ich drücke jetzt mal.
Eins.
Was ist denn das?
Also wenn es jetzt auch gleich so leckt, wenn wir auf dem Desktop drin sind, kann man es mal voll vergessen.
Zwei.
Moment.
Die Tastatur eingegangen sind und die Maus gekoppelt.
Guckt mal, ich drücke drei, es passiert nichts, ich bewege die Maus und es ist sofort da.
Ganz schön kaputt.
Gut, wir installieren jetzt eh gleich einen neuen Desktop.
Ja, da merkt man schon, dass es noch ein bisschen beta ist.
Tastatureingaben an Mausbewegung gekoppelt ist vielleicht nicht die cleverste Idee.
Ansonsten läuft es doch verhältnismäßig flüssig.
Oh.
Na ja.
Uuuh.
So, jetzt installieren wir erstmal Veränder-Tools, dass wir Fullscreen kriegen.
Ähm.
Open.
Open VM Tools.
Ach, wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreibt.
Oh, das Input-Lag des Todes.
Wenn ich die Maus bewege, dann kein Input-Lag, ob das so gewollt ist.
Install.
Open VM Tools.
Restart.
Wenn man die Maus bewegt, ist der Input schnell, das ist schon fail.
Machen wir das vorher noch?
Nee, wir installieren erstmal die VM-Tools.
Okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt, ich muss die Maus bewegen, dass es repainted.
Fail.
Perfekt.
Das, ich hoffe, das ist in der fertigen Version nicht so, sonst wäre ich das garantiert nicht verwenden.
So, ähm, VM-Ware.
User.
So, und jetzt sollten wir Fullscreen kriegen.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Ist es jetzt besser mit tippen?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Oh, das hakt ja.
Das ist hier neue User-Experience, das stimmt, man muss quasi mit einer Maus parallel, äh, mit einer Hand die ganze Zeit die Maus bewegen, dass man tippen darf.
Super.
Okay, dann darf der jetzt Updates machen.
Ich hoffe, das wird sich dann erledigen mit dem, wenn ich mal den Desktop hier umstelle, weil den GNOME 3 will ich eh nicht verwenden.
Wir suchen uns jetzt schon mal raus, das Repo, wo wir Sway herkriegen.
Gab es irgendwo, habe ich gesehen.
Sonst hätte ich jetzt, wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, das jetzt auszuprobieren.
Wo war das denn?
Also das ist alles ein bisschen hakelig irgendwie.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es ist wie gesagt, Beta uns, ein Monat vor Release ist für Ubuntu in der Regel ziemlich viel.
Die Releasen zwar jedes...
Was?
Der ist noch gar nicht fertig.
Ah.
Das sieht irgendwie alles noch ein bisschen kaputt aus.
Ähm, die Releasen zwar jedes halbe Jahr, deswegen würde man denken, hey, die müssten auch fast fertig sein, quasi ein Monat vor Release.
Aber bei Ubuntu ist das so, die sind eigentlich bei Release noch nicht mal fertig, richtig.
Das heißt, ein Monat vor Release ist Ubuntu noch sehr, sehr roh.
Als Nächste.
Ähm, nein, das hier will ich nicht.
Also ich will es mir bestimmt nicht selbst kompilieren, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Bye.
Sieht jetzt nicht nach so einem Megaakt aus.
Ein paar Abhängigkeiten installieren.
Also, falls es nicht geht, können wir das im Zweifelsfall auch selbst kompilieren.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so kompliziert aus.
Das ist zwar der Debian Installation Guide, aber der wird für Ubuntu bestimmt auch funktionieren.
Wo gab es denn das Ubuntu Repo?
Das da war das.
Jenox HDX fragt, wie steigt man am besten in Linux Einhab noch keine Erfahrung?
Ja, also das Beste ist, das mit Abstand, also meiner Ansicht nach mit Abstand das Beste ist,
du installierst dir eine Virtualisierungslösung, also sowas hier wie VMWare.
Und du siehst ja, ich habe hier Windows drum herum und in der VM läuft jetzt das Linux.
Du installierst dir VMWare Workstation, kannst dir, musst dir kaufen.
Du kannst dir auch VirtualBox installieren, das ist kostenlos, oder auch VMWare Player.
Und da kannst du ganz normal quasi in deinem Windows, wenn du es so willst,
einen virtuellen Rechner erstellen, in dem du dann ein Linux installierst.
Das ist zum Ausprobieren das beste Variante, die es gibt.
Und als Einsteiger-Distribution würde ich sagen, oh, ich habe eine Donation gekriegt.
Dafuck.
Musst gucken.
Der Domi hat donatet ein Euro, danke.
Und fragt, benutzt du, Moment, ich beantworte erst mal das andere, fertig.
Sonst vergesse ich, sonst komme ich durcheinander.
Als Einsteiger-Distribution würde ich entweder empfehlen Ubuntu.
Jetzt aber nicht unbedingt gerade die Beta-Version.
Wobei man sagen muss, Ubuntu ist als Einsteiger-Distribution gut,
allerdings in der VM nicht so sehr.
Zumindest bis jetzt, weil die Standard Ubuntu-Installation hat wie gesagt
einen eigenen Desktop, der in der VM nicht so gut läuft.
Das Ubuntu ist eine super Einsteiger-Installation, aber für VMs eher nicht.
Kann man aber machen.
Funktioniert gut genug.
Ansonsten, was ich persönlich super finde,
das ist aber ein bisschen was für Fortgeschrittene, ist Manjaro Linux.
Ist das System, was ich verwende.
Normalerweise kein Ubuntu.
Was auch ganz gut ist zum Einstieg, ist ein aktuelles Fedora.
Das ist auch ganz nice.
Da lernt man ein bisschen die Red Hat-Seite kennen, das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Oder aber man installiert sich ein Ubuntu und scheißt auf den Unity-Desktop
und installiert sich gleich einen anderen.
Dann funktioniert das nämlich auch super in der VM.
Aber in der VM testen ist das Beste.
Ich würde es nicht auf Hardware testen und schon gar nicht.
Ich würde irgendwie Gefahr laufen, meinen Rechner damit kaputt zu machen,
indem ich es irgendwie versuche parallel zu installieren oder sonst was.
Kann man den Scheiß nicht ausblenden da oben?
Das geht mir jetzt schon auf den Sack.
Das würde ich empfehlen.
Und jetzt zur Frage von der Donation.
Benutzt du Linux beziehungsweise Ubuntu als sekundäres Betriebssystem oder für was alles verwendest du es?
Also ich verwende Ubuntu auf der Arbeit.
Also quasi nur.
Habe ich auf meinem Rechner dort installiert.
Also sprich direkt auf der Hardware.
Da ist es in dem Fall Manjaro Linux.
Also es ist ein Archlinux drunter.
Zuhause habe ich auf meinem Desktop Windows.
Allein schon wegen den Spielen drauf.
Allerdings verwende ich auch eine VM mit Manjaro Linux.
Für alles was Netzwerksachen geht, Administrationsgedöns und eigentlich für alles wo man nicht unbedingt Windows braucht.
Und Linux läuft auch wunderbar in der VM.
Manjaro i3-WM drauf.
Super Umgebung.
Auf meinem Server läuft den Ubuntu Server 17.04.
Ich hoffe das beantwortet die Frage.
Ok.
Jetzt machen wir hier mal weiter.
So viele Fragen.
Kommt da gar nicht hinterher was zu machen.
Wie hat man diesen Mist hier oben noch mal ausgeplendet?
Das ging.
Konnte den Scheiß hier oben ausplendet, dass man es nicht mehr gesehen hat.
Wenn ich jetzt Exclusive Mode anmache, wie mache ich den wieder aus?
Ctrl-Alt-Key.
Ha!
So ist das.
Perfekt.
Jetzt kann ich hier, kann ich auch nicht mehr aus Versehen rausklicken und sowas.
Ja das ist gut.
Exclusive Mode.
Ähm.
The Blue Scream schreibt die VM.
Würde ich allerdings nur empfehlen, wenn man einen potenten PC hat.
Sonst ist die Experience kacke.
Es geht nicht.
Sonst ist er kacke, wenn ich einen potenten PC hat.
Sonst ist die Experience kacke.
Es geht eigentlich.
Also man muss schon...
Also man muss schon.
Man muss schon einen kacke Desktop haben, dass man keine VMs heutzutage ausführen kann.
Jeder halbwegs aktuelle Prozessor und jeder, jede halbwegs aktuelle Ram-Bestückung reichen
aus, um wunderbar ne Lilons-VM laufen zu lassen.
Kein problem, eine vm laufen zu lassen sei es jetzt mit mit vor immer workstation vor immer player wirtel box ist eigentlich vollkommen egal
Wenn das system so kacke ist dass man keine vm drauf laufen lassen kann
wird das system wird wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht ordentlich laufen wenn man es parallel installieren würde
Die kommt mir so voll ist die musik zu laut aber ist sie gar nicht da
Grad harte seitenarbeit angesagt
Okay, wo ist jetzt dass das das ah hier da ist es doch
installation package
Sway genau
Für maripos hinzu jetzt habe ich musikpläger startet als wollte ich das jetzt
exclusive mod
Ich bin so die die drei abkürzungen gewöhnt
Felix
Schreibt die musik ist gut ok also sagt einfach bescheid ob zu laut oder zu leise wenn irgendwas ist
Ich bin so die die shortcuts gewöhnt von i3 dass ich jetzt automatisch versucht mit windows taster 1 2 3 4 die desktop durch zu schalten
Dies hier gar nicht gibt
so
Hatte jetzt eigentlich abseits installiert ja das ist ok restart nein ja
Ja, komm wir lassen ihn noch mal restarten
Bitte ohne musik ich finde es eigentlich echt entspannend im hintergrund so ein bisschen
Bisschen klavier gdudel
Marvine das mit alienware ist noch nicht noch nicht spruchreif
Jetzt haben sie aber auch komisch gemacht dass jetzt das login jetzt kommt und danach noch mal auf die konsole geschaltet wird
Hallo wie wäre es mit wie wäre es mit auf fullscreen schalten Ubuntu
Wo schätzt nicht so jetzt installieren wir die drei
Man sieht schon das spakt ein bisschen rum hier guckt euch das mal an also das ist noch ziemlich unfertig
Habt ihr gerade gesehen das ding hat versucht auf fullscreen zu gehen hat gedacht nee ich bin gar nicht fullscreen das fenster tut nur so
ok
Das menü ruckelt auch
Also ist es halt mit 3d beschleunigt also mit mit
Grafik beschleunigen in vm das funktioniert in der regel nicht so gut
So dann fügen wir das mal hinzu dass repo mit sway drinne jawoll ich vertraue dem typ ich kenne ihn zwar nicht aber ich vertraue immer
Übrigens abgett ist
nicht mehr
So wie man es macht unter Ubuntu man verwendet jetzt nur noch abt
Weil warum auch immer ist jetzt halt so
Sprich damit hat jetzt quasi Ubuntu oder debian ich gehe mal davon aus bei debian es ist auch so damit hat es debian quasi
drei wege pakete zu installieren was abgett
Was abt was aptitude ach das gibt es gar nicht mehr. Ha okay das haben sie entfernt dann ist es vielleicht doch irgendeine Ubuntu sache
Das stimmt deswegen meinte ich vorhin
Das problem bei Ubuntu ist ist der der der standard desktop den sie da haben der funktioniert in der vm nicht gut ansonsten ist vor allem wenn er super
Ist Ubuntu super einsteiger distribution
So
Ja
Ähm ja und so nehmen wir den krempel mal
Was diesmal war firefox unten die meldung
Das war wahrscheinlich vor dem neustart oder ich habe es kommen zu spät gelesen
Das debian hat noch alle drei ja ich verstehe nicht was die was hier reitet quasi drei
Frontends für ihr oder zumindest kommando zeilen frontends für ihr paket verwaltung aus
Mit zu liefern verstehe ich nicht
Eins und gut ist
Okay jetzt haben wir es installiert ich gehe mal davon aus jetzt muss ich noch mal
Waeland neu starten wobei ist das überhaupt waeland jetzt hier oder ist das noch x wie findet man das raus
check if waeland running wir können mal gucken ob wir
So was hier gucken kann
Ja ja sieht nach waeland aus
x waeland
Aber haben sie nicht einfach nur waeland genannt
How to know waeland or x11 is being used
Stack overflow beste nein stack stack exchange ist ja admin stack overflow ist die programmier seite stack exchange ist die admin seite
Hat lock in ctl habe ich noch nie ausgeführt was ist das
Kehrt man auch nicht wirklich drauf
Was auch immer diese befehle da jetzt ah type waeland okay alles gut
Ah na das das sieht mir nach dem das sieht man nach der besseren lösung aus hier
Okay, es ist also waeland das ist nicht mehr x also nicht mehr nicht mehr x11
beziehungsweise nicht mehr xorg
Gut dann gucken wir mal ob der x-server neustart shortcut noch funktioniert unter waeland
ob
Funktioniert nicht mehr dann rebooten wir mal so wie man das von windows kennt
so und ich hoffe jetzt mal
x x waeland ist x x
Genau
x x waeland i scoped
x x waeland i scoped rebooten wir mal und dann hoffe ich dass man in diesem login manager auswählen kann
Sway also dass man im login manager sway auswählen darf
Also ich weiß nicht warum ubuntu so auf diese komische
Rauschen kurze farbgebung steht das ist mir unbegreiflich zwei sehr schön
Da ist er und das sieht aus wie i3 ich bin glücklich
So und wenn es jetzt noch ordentlich funktioniert
Wo genau im terminal sieht schon mal ziemlich fail aus mit dieser extra leiste hier um das vergleicht man die die
Das sie umstellen
Chrome haben wir natürlich noch nicht drauf binste wir machen uns jetzt mal ein ordentliches system was man benutzen kann
Da kann ich aber ein bisschen sway ausprobieren
Ich kann
Hallo
Das ding hat ein bisschen probleme mit maus und tastatur würde ich mal sagen
Menüs anklicken kann ich allerdings menüpunkte funktioniert nicht aber mit tastatur geht's
Weil warum auch immer
So das erste und wichtigste ist man braucht ein ordentliches
Farbschema
Ist das nervig und hier dies dieses maus zeiger und dann ist das das karat für tech das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt
Das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt hier würde ich sagen
Kann man was hat das was hatten das klobenturm mit den standardmäßig für für farbschema dabei
Das das backt alles übelst rum die maus backt total
Ich kann hier nichts auswählen seht ihr das
Oh, das ist ja fein ich muss jetzt dass das funktioniert ich muss jetzt links klicken und mit der tastatur hoch und runter drücken
Und die solare ist halt ich nicht aus es soll er heißt haltschneid aus
Greed und pleck nee wisst ihr wir installieren jetzt erstmal kurz in chrome
Wir installieren uns jetzt erstmal in chrome und dann installieren wir ein ordentliches konsolen farbschema
Weil ohne kann man nicht arbeiten
Und dann müssen wir als nächstes noch eine ordentliche schriftart installieren
Und dann müssen wir das chrome klobenterminal, aber ich glaube das ist jetzt nicht mehr ein klobenterminal
Aber ich glaube das ist jetzt nicht mehr ein klobenterminal
Und dann müssen wir als nächstes noch eine ordentliche schriftart installieren und dann müssen wir das chrome klobenterminal
Aber ich glaube das ist wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie in den wailent
Knoam sonst was backt dass ich hier mit der maus nicht so nicht richtig auswählen kann und hier auch maus zeige und und text
Und so dass das alles nicht so ganz stimmt
Ihr seht ja guck mal das ist irgendwie irgendwie nicht so nicht so nicht so wie das
moment jetzt geht das
Eben ging es
Mit mit anklicken okay, das ist fail
Okay, starten wir mal in chrome
So
Bestes konsolen farbschema
Der hier also beziehungsweise es ist kein konsolen farbschema das ist
Allgemein für für alle möglichen programe
alle möglichen programe gibt es das
Was die pric
Please see read me
Wie entwickel der typ das nicht mehr weiter
So
Ich hätte es gern für klobenterminal. Ach hier gibt's ja
Genau den will ich haben
Und für schelle
Schelle
Klohn war uns das war so wir müssen nämlich das terminal jetzt erst mal dunkel machen gibt ja augenkrebs sonst
Ist im git installiert was kein git
Bei der gelegenheit können wir gleich mal git installieren und wir installieren mal bild tools
Falls wir irgendwas noch selbst kompilieren müssen später
Aber ich habe jetzt einige fragen glaube ich übersehen
Chris livisel fragt kam das git tutorial schon nie kam noch nicht
Nur an art fragt welchen text editor nutzt du eigentlich im terminal wim
Hauptsächlich schwimmt wenn es wenn es im terminal sein muss so kopieren
Copy sagt man ist das copy paste kaputt vielleicht
Ich glaube das copy paste ist kaputt das ist natürlich doof wenn copy paste nicht funktioniert
Na copy paste ist kaputt
Das sagt geht es denn umgedreht copy
Nee copy paste ist kaputt legt es am chrome oder legt es vielleicht am
Browser
Copy paste geht nicht das ist ziemlich scheiße dass copy und paste nicht mehr in licht geht wisst ihr das
Schiebt das mal ich schieb das mal auf beta
Das sagt es kann doch nicht sein dass copy und paste nicht funktioniert
So ich will das hier will ich klonen
Also hier funktioniert copy und paste so und hier nicht ganz toll
Gut dann scheißen wir mal auf knob terminal
Wir nehmen jetzt mal den klassiker
Zumindest
Darf ich hier copy paste hier funktioniert copy und paste
Dafür sieht hier das der maus zeigen auch hässlicher aus drin
Oh nee nee nee nee nee x-term halte ich nicht aus was kann man sonst noch für ein terminal installieren wir könnten wir wir probieren jetzt mal
Dass wir probieren jetzt mal das kde terminal aus
Das verwende werde ich aber nicht verwenden
Ich will einfach nur mal wissen ob es funktioniert das scheint ja nämlich hier noch ein paar probleme zu geben
Boah so wir installieren jetzt erstmal halb kde mit dass wir dann dass wir dann dass wir terminal installiert bekommen
Ist es normal dass man gelbleckt wenn ich nebenher stream schaue fragt iron horse das kann sein
Nachdem wieder ein rechner ausgelastet ist und ob hardware decoder verwendet wird cpu decoder oder sonst was
Nee terminator mag ich nicht
Ja nach ich also es funktioniert beides nicht blue screen mittlere maustaste und und und also hier control shift cv
Funktioniert beides nicht
Hier geht es drinne
Hier geht es
Und hier geht auch hier geht auch die mp3
Und hier geht es auch hier geht auch die mp3
hier gehts und hier geht auch hier gehen auch die Menüs
der Mauszeiger sieht zwar immer noch ziemlich feil und kaputt aus
aber ich mein, who cares, ne Moment, jetzt gehen die Menüs wieder nicht
das ist ja mega kaputter Scheiß, also das schieb ich mal auf die noch ziemlich schlechte Wayland-Unterstützung
Stimmt, haben die den echten Donate-Button? Donate, jawoll, die beste Donate-Button in der Konsole, ja warum nicht
also irgendwie wenn man noch nicht mal eine Konsole ordentlich zum Laufen kriegt
wie siehts denn mit LX-Terminal aus, wir installieren jetzt mal ein paar Konsolenfenster und gucken mal wie die ausschauen
LX-Terminal ist auch GTK-Anwendung
ok hier funktioniert das Menü, hier funktioniert denn hier Copy und Paste
hier funktioniert auch Copy und Paste, also das Gnome-Terminal scheint ziemlich Probleme zu haben
Gnome-Terminal funktioniert kein Copy und Paste, hat kein Bock, will nicht, das Gnome-Terminal ist generell ziemlich kaputt
aber hier, hier, oh jetzt sind die Menüs wieder kaputt, oh ist das fail, egal, wir klauen jetzt erstmal das Repo und machen uns ein ordentliches Konsolen-Farbschema
und vorher installieren wir eine ordentliche Schriftart
search
so
Hack wollen wir installieren, beste Schriftart, braucht man Hack, nee Fonts Hack
das braucht man, die ist essentiell, ohne die geht das nicht
danach mach ich die Schrift, machen wir hier ein bisschen größer
also ich muss sagen, der Display-Manager, äh der Window-Manager funktioniert fast rein
die Programme funktionieren nicht so richtig, aber da kann Sway ja nix für
oh das sieht auch schonmal elektrisch aus, das sieht ja ja aus wie 1995 so
so wir wollen Hack haben
Hack
Schriftgröße waren wir 16 oder so, ah, das ist doch gut
so und jetzt können wir das klonen, gucken ob das Farbschema funktioniert
Green of Black, nee Green of Black, Green of Black geht nicht
Base 16 ist das beste Farbschema finde ich
Moment
wie füllt man das jetzt aus
Z-Shell muss man auch installieren
Color-Test
wat
ah
Base 16 Tomorrow Night wollen wir haben
Permission Denied, ja, Source
Ha, so ist das schön, so gefällt mir das
was, bestes, bestes Farbschema
allerdings der Hintergrund stimmt nicht
den Hintergrund müssen wir wahrscheinlich dann noch
also Konsolenfarbschema, das ist das, das, das sonst kann man nicht arbeiten, das funktioniert nicht
so, da müssen wir installieren
ja
das muss sein
was wir brauchen, den Hintergrund, zeig mal Eveli, was ist das für ein Hintergrund
woa
er ist ja auch ein Gravespy
das sieht doch schon ganz, ganz brauchbar aus
wie kann man, wie kann man Alex Terminal denn den Hintergrund verstellen, geht das überhaupt
wir gucken noch mal, wie es bei Gnome Terminal aussieht
normalerweise verwende ich Gnome Terminal, allerdings spackt das hier gerade extrem rum
Scripts
so gefällt mir das, wenn ich jetzt hier oben, wir müssen unbedingt gucken, wie man ordentliche Gnome Teams einstellt
so gefällt mir das
also Gnome Terminal hat echt Probleme hier
hack
so ist das gut
so ist das gut, so muss das sein, so muss das schnell aussehen
wenn jetzt noch Copy-Paste funktionieren würde
LOL 3D
das ist doch schön, jetzt haben wir eine Shell, die gut aussieht, Problem ist, Copy-Paste geht nicht
aber wie heißt dieses Gnome Clipboard oder so, die hatten doch so einen eigenen Clipboard Manager
nicht install search
Clipper
ich muss unbedingt meine Alias wieder anlegen
weil jetzt kann man so machen, bestes Alias braucht man
sonst muss man immer ganze Zeit sudo tippen
und übrigens soll ich euch nochmal was cooles zeigen, einen richtig krassen Hex hier
mal angenommen ihr habt das hier jetzt ausgeführt und sagt, oh fuck ich hab vergessen sudo einzugeben
dann gebt ihr ein sudo, so und dann macht das, das führt den letzten Befehl nochmal aus
und jetzt die Premium Variante, ihr habt festgestellt, oh fuck ich hab vergessen sudo einzugeben
tak bam in your face, führt er aus, richtig krasser Hex oder
Geh-Paste
sollte der nicht eigentlich hier oben normalerweise jetzt so ne Menü Area haben
mein Plon ja
was gibt's denn sonst noch für Insta
jetzt kann aber die Shell das nochmal passen, gibt's irgendwelche Clipboard Manager die funktionieren
hallo, dafuck, wat
ah das kann sein, dass ich das erst konfigurieren muss, dass er den Kram hier oben anzeigt
das ist eigentlich alles ganz schöner Fail oder, das Copy Paste nicht ordentlich funktioniert
wo sind wir denn, wir sind im Jahr 2017 hallo
ne funktioniert immer noch nicht, ja super Geh-Paste, wie startet man das denn, Geh-Paste
so Sway, Sway Notification Area, wie macht man das
ich brauch hier oben so ne Anzeige für, für, für Tray Items
wie macht man das, wie, wie zeigt man eine Tray Area an in Sway
muss doch gehen, wenn es nicht geht wäre er echt witzlos
wie, wie macht man in Sway Tray Area
wo sind meine Tray Items, Sway Wiki, Gott Tray Items
wie jetzt, hallo ich will Tray Items haben, das kann doch nicht sein, dass das Ding keine
Tray Items kann der Domi, hast du schonmal was von Ubuntu
Phones gehört, ja aber ich dachte das ist mittlerweile tot
ok, dann gucken wir, wir gucken jetzt mal in die Konfig rein von Sway
Sway, Sway, wie, Konfig, Sway, aber ich glaube wir müssen erstmal nen Vim installieren
ähm, übrigens ich will keinen Vim, ich will nen Vim, äh nen Vim
mit grafischer Oberfläche, allerdings nicht, ich will die grafische Oberfläche nicht verwenden
ich weiß nur, wenn man nen Vim mit grafischer Oberfläche installiert, dann ist auf jeden
Fall alles dabei, Sway, Sway Konfig, Sway Konfig
wie konfiguriert man Sway, Konfiguration, ja ich benutze die I3, aber ich hab meine
I3 Konfig hier nicht, etc Sway Konfig, ok die kann man anscheinend anpassen, oh nein
ich kann den nicht copy paste, hab ich ja ganz vergessen, fail, und dann wo soll ich die
hin kopieren, wahrscheinlich nach Punkt Konfig Sway oder sowas, ich hoffe mal das stimmt
hier, ist jetzt einfach, ups, ist jetzt einfach geraten, ups, was mach ich denn hier, so Konfig,
Sway, ähm Bar, Position Bar, Top Colors, Sway, Sway Output, Sway Output Primary, also ok,
so, oh ich kann den nicht copy pasten, ich krieg, ich krieg, ey ich krieg, das geht nicht,
das halt ich nicht aus, das halt ich nicht aus, wenn ich nicht copy pasten kann, was
Sway Output Primary, so und jetzt das Ding reloaden, ist das hier gleiche Shotcut wie
bei I3, reload, Mod, Shift, C, was Mod, Mod, Mod, Shift, Shift, C, hab ich jetzt ein Tray,
what the fuck, ich will doch einfach nur das Copy Paste funktioniert, also sowas muss auch
unter einem Beta Ubuntu funktionieren und ich will System Trays haben, wir kriegen das
schon hin, was gibt's noch für Clipboard Manager, was gibt's denn da alles, ich probier
die jetzt alle durch, bis einer funktioniert, ja, Archwiki Beste, Copy Q, klingt gut, hat
auch gute Bewertung, das verwenden wir jetzt, Copy Q, gibt's das J? Gibt's natürlich nicht,
wenn ich das dann doch richtig schreib, gibt's nicht, sowas gibt's denn sonst noch für
Clipboard Manager, Clip It, G Paste, ja G Paste haben wir grad installiert, mit, oh ich
kann nicht Copy Pasteen, benutzt du für Windows auch einen Clipboard Manager, ne, unter Windows
funktioniert sowas in der Regel, auch ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass ich das jemals
habe, ja, oder Windows funktioniert die Zwischenablage, ja Roman, ich teste Ubuntu Beta und verzweifle
an Zwischenablage, yes, natürlich, ok, jetzt, ich hab jetzt einen Clipboard Manager laufen,
fuck man, das geht einfach nicht, das geht einfach nicht, das Chrome Terminal verbugt,
ok, und wir haben immer noch kein System Tray, verwende, Moment, verwende das Ding hier überhaupt
diese Config, probieren wir mal aus, wir machen die Config jetzt kaputt, und jetzt sollte er
ja sagen, er kann nicht, ok, da nimmt die Config schon mal gar nicht, wo muss denn das Sway
Config, Location, Configuration, nach Punkt, ja hab ich doch gemacht, hab ich doch gemacht,
hab ich doch, da hab ich es doch hinkopiert, ahhh, Copy Paste geht nicht, hab ich doch
gemacht, Punkt, Config, Sway, Config, genau, da hab ich die hinkopiert, und jetzt würde
ich erwarten, dass der meckert, wenn er das nicht laden kann, Sway Config hab ich doch
gemacht, also wenns, wenns bei so einfachen Dinger schon hakt, ey, ich mein ich mach jetzt
die Config kaputt, ach wir haben ja noch nicht mal die richtige Shell hier laufen, starte
den Knopf jetzt gleich nochmal neu, Mod 4 ist Windows Taste, alles gut, ok, also mit
Windows Taste schalten wir um, dann stellen wir das jetzt mal hier um auf Alt, dann sollte
es ja eigentlich nicht mehr gehen, da nimmt die Config nicht, ok wir schreiben hier nochmal
irgendeine Scheiße rein und starten, wie kann man eigentlich nur Sway Restarten, geht das?
Ja, Irvoli hast recht, ich mach jetzt ein Reboot, also Copy und Paste hätt ich jetzt
erwartet, dass es mit so verbreiteten, also dass es da im Zusammenspiel keine Probleme
gibt, weil ich mein, ein Chrome bzw. Firefox als Browser und ein Knoom Terminal als Terminal,
das muss gehen und Tray Icons müssen auch funktionieren, sonst ist das ganze ja komplett
unbrauchbar und ich glaube jetzt hängt es beim Reboot oder sowas, Perfekt, Beste, macht
er noch was, Scheiß drauf, neu start, also ich hab jetzt irgendeinen Mist in die Config
geschrieben, ihr habt es ja gesehen und vorhin hab ich gesagt, do not show again, kann man
mit Visual Studio Code sinnvoll C programmieren, fragt X der Shadow Ghost, ja kann man, kann
man mit Visual Studio Code und den passenden Plugins fast alles machen, Moment, jetzt geht
noch nicht mal, Vollbild, Alter was ist denn hier los, jetzt hab ich echt gleich keinen
Job mehr, das ist doch nicht normal, das Ding schaltet sich nicht mal mehr auf Vollbild,
voll, darf ich, darf ich es von Hand umschalten, wie auch immer das ging, was weiß ich, wie
ging das überhaupt, ne, can not fit me, ist mir auch klar, was geht denn bitteschön
hier ab, oh ich kann nicht mehr tippen, ah doch geht, das funktioniert noch nicht so
richtig gut, sway config, wisst ihr was, ich lösche die jetzt wieder, das Menü geht
aber noch, config sway, ich lösche die config jetzt wieder, ich lösche das ganze Verzeichnis,
jetzt reboot ich noch mal, ok jetzt startet es schon mal neu, ob jetzt auch immer jetzt
ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Zeichen ist, keine Ahnung, iso und wann das programmieren
weiter geht spätestens mit dem neuen Windows Update, was nächsten Monat kommt, also in
14 Tagen ungefähr oder in 13, jetzt hab ich vergessen was ich sag, ah, na es funktioniert,
es lag an der config, Moment, da stimmt doch irgendwas net, hier stimmt doch irgendwas
net, ok, tray Sachen funktionieren schon mal gar nicht, äh, gnome, wie ist der Kram
noch mal, geb, geb haste, der funktioniert auch nicht, ok dann starten wir jetzt noch
mal ein Chrome, was wollte man eigentlich ursprünglich machen, oh ich krieg echt die
Krise, nein, copy und paste, das geht nicht, das ist nicht erlaubt, dann verwenden wir
jetzt ein anderes Terminal, wo copy und paste funktioniert, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal das,
was der Vater eben vorgeschlagen hat, nehmen wir mal einen Terminator, ja sie baue, das
stimmt, das hatte ich ja eben auch schon, das spackt auch so, ok anscheinend alles GTK basierte
spackt bei copy pasten, ich starte jetzt nochmal gnome und gucke ob das da auch so ist, äh,
usar, moin, lässt du ja dein linux was im Alltag nutzt auch immer über ne vm laufen,
oder, ne, also das linux was ich auf der Arbeit verwende nicht, ah hier kann man umschalten,
ok, das äh, benutze ich auf der Hard, ist direkt auf der Hard verinstalliert, aber auf
meinem lestop verwende ich das in der Regel in der vm, weil ich ja das Windows zum Spielen
brauche, so mal gucken ob jetzt wenigstens in gnome selbst das copy und paste ordentlich
funktioniert, ok hier funktioniert es, das wäre jetzt ja auch ein witz gewesen, ne hier
funktioniert es auch nicht, oder, warte mal, doch hier funktioniert es, ok, also in gnome
selbst funktioniert der kram, kann man, warum kann man eigentlich nicht logout machen, das
ist echt, ah doch logout, dann liegt es irgendwie am zusammenspiel zwischen gnome und sway,
das will irgendwie nicht, dann nehmen wir jetzt kde konsole, meinetwegen kann ich auch mit
leben, ah, gut, ok, das macht einfach nichts, ist auch toll, lol, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Da hat aber der Hintergrund nicht funktioniert, ja geil wir haben kein Terminal was ordentlich funktioniert perfekt
Das ist ja das ist ja eine tolle Auswahl
Dürfen wir vielleicht dürfen vielleicht jetzt
Eine warte dass ich hier so komische
Zeilen obendran hab sway config file wir müssen uns jetzt mal config file anlegen
Okay was nehmen wir jetzt, NX Terminal nehmen wir jetzt. Sieht zwar nicht schön aus aber funktioniert
config, okay
Gut
So dann passen wir die config mal ein bisschen an
Sieht das hässlich aus gibt es nicht irgendein terminal was funktioniert
X flame hat was ich heute mache ich will mir das neue Ubuntu angucken mit dem neuen display manager aber es scheitert schon daran dass copy und
paste nicht ordentlich funktioniert
Und menüs und sowas guck du siehst die verschwinden immer zwischendurch das ist alles noch ziemlich unfertig
So jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Farbe
Passen wir die config mal an
Das brauchen wir eigentlich alles nicht, das können wir alles default lassen
Gibt es jetzt sowas wie quit, sway, quit
Wie kommt man da wieder raus ohne neu zu starten was ist ich verwende das normaler ich quitte den ja normalerweise nicht
Mod shift e mod shift e ha funktioniert
Cool immerhin immerhin
Das wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr neu starten um die config auszuprobieren
Tray output primary hofft das funktioniert jetzt so
Haben wir jetzt haben wir jetzt ein tray
Immer noch kein Tray das kann doch nicht sein was ist das für ein fail
Ich will einfach eine anzeige von eigens im tray haben
Also das scheitert ja gerade schon eine ganz grundlegenden sachen dass es funktioniert
Moment wie heißt mein output da wäre ich ja nie drauf gekommen
Mein output heißt virtual minus eins das kryptischer geht es nicht mehr
Tray heißt heißt mein heißt das ding allen ernstes virtual minus eins
Kann doch gar nicht sein das ist von beknackter name
Okay ich habe keine ahnung wie man sich tray eigens anzeigen lassen kann
Was gibt es gibt es in kade e clipboard manager klipper ist irgendwas neues
Clip man die und dann ich installiere jetzt den ganzen kram bis ich den clipboard manager
Habe der funktioniert aber ist wie copy paste funktioniert wenn ich den kram
irgendwann mal verwenden muss also das zeug startet und sollte auch funktionieren
aber ich habe hier kein kein tray was eigens anzeigt das ist echt fail
okay was unterstützen die die unterstützen plus notification eigens mit status
not ich habe keine ahnung was ich hier mache
wie ist das ding klipp klipp koppikuh das ding verwenden wir jetzt
ubuntu aber komm her in den clipboard manager funktioniert
not faun und nun bleiben wir hängen oder was der hat noch keine der hat noch keine
okay der hat noch keine pakete für das neue ubuntu kann das sein
meine grüte kann man bei ubuntu kde reinladen ja klar ganz kde starten ganz kde installieren
ganz kde starten funktioniert
wir kompilieren uns den jetzt wir kompilieren uns das jetzt
ich glaube ja das problem liegt daran dass meine config nicht richtig geladen wird
wir können es ja schon mal ausprobieren wir stellen hier einfach mal position bottom bottom
dann würde ich sagen die bar sollte unten sein okay das funktioniert also im prinzip
also die die config wird geladen ja also dann dann probier was noch mal anders
weil es ist natürlich bescheuert dass in wayland mit mit x tools kucke kann man unity für
anstellungs nutzen theoretisch schon aber ich weiß warum warum alles in der welt will man
unity verwenden ich sehe nichts es funktioniert einfach nicht es gibt keine tray eigens was
gibt es noch für programme mit tray
was ich machen will ich will mir einen clipboard manager installieren dass ich den gnome terminal
ordentlich copy pasten kann weil das ja anscheinend hier noch verbugt ist ein ordentlichen clipboard
manager funktioniert das bestimmt allerdings clipboard manager kann ich mir nicht installieren
weil ich keine tray eigens angezeigt kriege dass ich dann sehe ich nix das ist ganz das
ist echt fail wie soll man das überhaupt verwenden ohne tray eigens und wenn copy paste
nicht richtig funktioniert und alles
wollen wir
welche outputs muss ich da eingeben überhaupt
ok x-rande soll nicht verwendet werden ok output virtual minus eins was soll ich jetzt
output ok also der richtige name wäre ja wahrscheinlich wird schon minus eins aber wenn ich den hier
eintrage für tray eigens dann klappt es nicht den starte zeigt keine tray eigens an an ist
das fail dann weiß ich auch nicht was ich jetzt noch machen soll wenn ich mal sagen
der test ist ganz schön in die hose gegangen
der starte das ding aber es kommt halt nichts im tray an aber copy und pasten na gut das
zeigt auch keine fehler an also irgendwie ist das noch sehr sehr hakelig alles eine
versuche probieren wir jetzt noch
moment habe ich auch die richtige version habe ich überhaupt die richtige version von
diesem ding aber habe ich auch die richtige version ne habe ich net das allernstes es
gibt eine halbwegs aktuelle sway version die keine tray eigens unterstützt was ist das
denn da habe ich ja gar keinen bock weiterzumachen
also ernsthaft jetzt soll ich soll ich mir wirklich jetzt einen sway 014 kompilieren
nur dass ich tray eigens verwenden kann und dass ich den display dass ich den clipboard
manager starten kann dass ich im genauen terminal copy und pasten kann es ist 2017 wtf das ding
zeigt ja auch schon mal überhaupt keine fehler an oder so selbst wenn ich den scheiß angebe
das juckt es einfach nicht
also ich bin nicht überzeugt muss ich jetzt mal sagen nicht ansatzweise also wenn das
die zukunft sein soll von linux desktop dann sehe ich ja schwarz ne das neue gibt es noch
nicht im repo im repo gibt es nur gibt plus 13 moment die dessen übersteuert naja gut
das können wir sonst noch ausprobieren wir können jetzt mal also wenn wir jetzt mal davon
absehen dass tray eigens nicht ordentlich funktionieren okay und wir dementsprechend
kein also alle gtk basierten terminals funktionieren die menus nicht richtig siehe siehe hier so
dinge an bei chrome terminal funktioniert hier schon mal gar nichts richtig und auch kein
copy paste hier in elixir funktioniert wenigstens copy und paste im terminal im terminator funktioniert
nichts richtig
wir können auch mal ein ordentliches theme für gtk anwendungen installieren dass es
dann immer ganz so hässlich aussieht was gibt es denn sonst noch für terminals jetzt
mal von xterm und uxt abgesehen sind irgendwelche neuen sachen die sich lohnen zu verwenden
wo vielleicht alles funktioniert konsole ist ganz okay das funktioniert noch am besten
kann aber ein paar sachen nicht ich haben will xterm na xterm ist mir zu oldschool cool
die retro turn da fack warum hat es so viele bewertungen
okay das ist eher ein kunstprojekt anstatt was man wirklich verwenden möchte
elixir funktioniert am besten
ich brauche ordentlich terminal color sonst dreh ich durch
das könnten wir noch mal installieren das war ganz gut das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert
das war ganz gut gucken ob es das für ubuntu gibt
gucken ob es das für ubuntu gibt ja zum selbst kompilieren
kann man machen dann kompilieren wir uns das jetzt selbst dann haben vielleicht ein terminal
was funktioniert die looks auf dem desktop lull wir können aber einfach das skript von
dem typ neben das sieht nämlich ziemlich gut aus so als wenn es einfach funktionieren
vielleicht haben wir dann ein terminal was ordentlich funktioniert das habe ich früher
schon eine weile verwendet das war ganz okay basiert auch auf dem ganzen gnome zeug aber
ohne hier so viel müll drum herum
am liebsten verwende ich ehrlich gesagt gnome terminal deswegen ärgert es mich ein bisschen
dass es hier nicht richtig funktioniert
so lieber noch mal das terminal
hier der kompiliert jetzt terminal wie alle ich glaube sind wir kompilieren uns ein terminal
damit copy und paste funktioniert wo sind wir dann okay das sieht nicht das sieht nicht
richtig aus das sieht nicht richtig aus leute da stimmt was nicht das sieht nicht gut aus
so sollte es bestimmt nicht aussehen und den rahmen mit ubuntu fenstern solltest du eigentlich
auch nicht haben terminal irgendwie ist das alles nicht so ganz fertig klappt dann copy
und paste nein natürlich nicht was der kacke copy und paste funktioniert
ja was immer dazu sagen
ja das mache ich auch gleich also das da ist mir dann auch die zeit für zu schade
guck mal ob es hier funktioniert mit copy und paste aber auch das hat auch gnome ob
einfach nicht mal copy paste geht ich krieg echt die grise kann doch nicht sein so lächerlich
das ist vielleicht generell ein bug was ich auch merkwürdig finde ist hier das aber
das verschieben für funktioniert halbwegs also es scheint scheint kein generelles problem
zu geben
was hast du schon mal probiert im gleichen desktop copy paste zu machen achso ich kann
es mal ausprobieren aber ich hoffe ich hoffe mal nicht bringt nichts geht nicht copy paste
geht nicht also ich hoffe mal nicht dass das die die zukunft das lx terminal funktioniert
auch am besten aber auch nicht schön am besten hat bisher eigentlich das ganze kde zeug funktioniert
was ist das hier ne das ist alles noch ziemlich ziemlich unfertig und kaputt also wenn das
in diesem zustand rauskommt moment wisst ihr was wir jetzt eine sache machen wir noch
mal die sind doch jetzt auch auf wehlen oder fedora ok wir installieren es noch mal schnell
fedora ich will einfach nur gucken ob das ein problem ist von der ubuntu beta dass es
alles nicht richtig funktioniert
das machen wir jetzt aber das jetzt schon wo man es doch schnell ausprobieren aber
noch in fedora installieren und gucken ob diese ganze probleme an der ubuntu beta liegen
oder ob das ein generelles problem ist mit sway und weiland ja gut dann dann laden wir
das ist nämlich noch ein fedora runter ein aktuelles
und dann schauen wir mal ob das ob das da auch so kaputt ist ich hoffe ja nicht weil
weil wenn das die zukunft sein soll dann hänge ich ja noch hänge ich wahrscheinlich die
nächsten fünf jahre noch auf x org rum weil ich mein das copy und paste funktioniert
das tray erikens funktionieren dass man gescheit fenster resize kann und solche sachen das
sollte das sollte standard sein das ist nichts mehr wo man auch nur einen gedanken dran
verschwenden sollte 2017 das muss einfach funktionieren also ich meine dass ich die
programme installieren muss dafür ok aber danach sollte alles out of the box einfach
tun und für copy und paste muss ich auch nichts installieren das muss einfach gehen also das
kann es nicht sein zu einem minuten das geht schnell was hast du normal das jetzt wenn
aus zehn ja das ist wenn aus zehn allerdings wie gesagt für extra für streaming zwecke
einfach hier in der default mit den default einstellungen alles ich habe ein extra account
gemacht zum stream dass ich nicht nur aus versehen meine porn sammlung zeigen oder so
so ob und wo machen wir platt und danach wenn es mit fedora also je nachdem eigentlich egal
ob es funktioniert oder nicht das war nur zum testen und dann haben wir die vm wieder platt
das heißt jetzt halt nur noch ob und wo ist aber wurscht wie die vm heißt 0 hat ja ich
habe auf meinem server läuft es läuft fast alles als vm als vm oder als lxc-container
aufladen runter
rups vielleicht sollte ich noch mal einstellen dass da auch das laufwerk startet ich habe
gesagt neu starten start start ist gut gestartet vielleicht hat fedora auch mal so wie das
man jaro beispielsweise hat standardmäßig die vm tools dabei ich finde so nervig dass
man auf den meisten distribution vm tools nach installieren muss warum werden die nicht
einfach mitgeliefert ich gehe mal davon aus fallen desktop bereich also sprich alle distributionen
die sich irgendwie auch so ein bisschen am desktop bereich richten weil sie halt mit
grafischer oberfläche daherkommen standardmäßig ganz großer teil davon läuft eben in der
vm deswegen warum nicht einfach verämbertool standardmäßig installieren ha fedora hat
vor allem der toolstand ist installiert das ist mir doch recht sympathisch und das läuft
auch relativ schnell muss ich sagen und es ist auch weiland ok also prinzipiell scheint
das tatsächlich dann eher ubuntu zu legen ok wir installieren uns fedora die musik im
hintergrund ist kann ich dir schicken ist das hier the very best ist das the very best
das ist einfach ein video was zwei stunden geht moment was sehe ich das richtig man kann
fedora in irgendeinem deutschen dialect installieren ist das denn ihr ernst ja gut meinetwegen
ja ich würde gerne hier noch tastatur umstellen da darf ich anscheinend nicht jetzt hat das
eingestellt ja die fedora installation war schon immer merkwürdig kann ich nicht einfach
sagen hau alles weg ja löscht den scheiß einfach brauchst du eh nicht mehr alles löschen
was ok installation starten ok root password nein ich will eigentlich kein root password
ich will sudo und scheiß drauf vergeb ich halt ein root password so ein wahnsinnig secure
benutzer test admin auch wieder high secure password ok jetzt muss ich warten bis der
installation ist das ging schnell den installer ist cool auf guck mal die faken noch nicht
mal den fortschritts balken die zeigen ihn einfach standardmäßig als voll an so kann
man das auch machen möchten sie fedora besser machen wir können ihnen helfen wir können
ihnen helfen uns zu helfen ach so viel plus hat der donate button aber ich muss sagen
wenn ich mir wenn ich überlege was das früher schon für eine für einen akt teilweise war
und die installer manchmal abgekackt sind zwischendurch wenigstens das funktioniert
mittlerweile gut weil das ist guck mal also die fedora installation das war jetzt ja fast
idiotensicher da kann man eigentlich nichts falsch machen und was hat hot dog mit fedora
zu tun ja das frage ich mich auch das ist eine gute frage den hätten sie wenigstens
noch einen hut aufsetzen könnte oder aber zu erledigen installieren sie lipro office
um text und abend zu erstellen und noch viel mehr ich gehe mal davon aus dass lipro office
sogar standardmäßig dabei ist aber wenn sie es irgendwie vermeiden lässt verwende
ich diese ganzen office geschichten nicht ich glaube kein mensch braucht wirklich eine
textverarbeitung keiner braucht eine text ich habe noch kein anwendungszweck erlebt
wurde gesagt hätte ja wohl ich brauche jetzt eine textverarbeitung weil es ist einfach
so wenn man text schreiben will kann man das in einem text in die tor machen und da gibt
es auch so was wie recht schreibkontrolle und so was ja wenn ich was schön formatieren
will dann gibt es auch verschiedene möglichkeiten die einfachste variante ist wenn ich wenn
ich das mit markdown zum beispiel mache gut damit kann man jetzt nicht gar so komplizierte
sachen machen ja wenn ich ein bisschen fernseher machen will macht mit tech oder im zweifelsfall
wenn es für irgendwelche layout sachen ist da macht mit dem layoutprogramm also eigentlich
braucht man keine textverarbeitung also ich glaube ich hatte jetzt ohne witz ich hatte
zum letzten mal wort auf vor sechs jahren oder so ich glaube ich habe es glaube ich
gar nicht mehr installiert habe ich überhaupt installiert habe ich habe ich lipro office
ja das habe ich installiert okay verwende ich net auch tabellen kann ich verwende ich
verwende eigentlich keine office programmer mehr weil ich weiß gar nicht wofür vollständig
nach einem neustart können sie beginnen ich glaube ich glaube in markdown kommt theoretisch
jeder klar das gibt drei vier sachen die man sich merken muss das war es aber gut für
irgendwelche fancy sachen ist markdown jetzt auch nichts also muss dann wirklich auch ein
ordentliches layout haben muss ja das dafür aber das wollen die meisten leute noch nicht
mal hallo ich wollte neu starten das startet sogar automatisch funktioniert einfach selbst
für powerpoint präsentation selbst dafür kann man sich darüber streiten es gibt richtig
viele coole browser basierte präsentation tools mittlerweile es gibt auch präsentation
tool wo man präsentation komplett in markdown erstellen kann ich finde das alles irgendwie
einfacher und schöner als mit mit powerpoint also rum zu wurschteln auch kommt mal hier
ist übrigens die tastatureingabe und das das neu zeichnen des fensters nicht an tastatureingaben
gebunden unglaublich es funktioniert aber schwarz wird es trotzdem danach warum auch
immer aber das läuft schon mal eine ganze ecke ok einrichtungsassistent ok mal was
hat ein deutsch ne wir machen die sprache in englisch gut das geht ja wenigstens und
text location services brauchen wir nicht brauchen wir auch nicht next nein ich will
mich nicht verbinden start using jawoll verpiss dich also das läuft schon viel besser als
das ubuntu als das das beta ubuntu muss man auch so sagen dass es war ja beta ok und jetzt
ist der leber mass way dfm oder wie fack wie ist der neue rett hat paket manager die df
jam ist jam war gestern jam verwendet man ja nicht mehr die dnf hieß ist die nf genau
install suede alle wollen so dass man irgendwo accounts macht ich will keine kaufmann ich will
den graf einfach verwenden nice scheint zu funktionieren es ist zwar lahm aber rpm basiert
distribution sind immer schnarch langsam bei updates und bei paketquellen aktualisieren
alles das zeichnet so dieses ganze rpm zeug aus das ist einfach so krass langsam nicht
dass die an pakete so viel besser werden am besten gefällt mir das paketsystem von archlinux
alles ziemlich leichtgewichtig guck mal die haben sogar das neueste sway da kann man sogar
drei eigentlich wahrscheinlich verwenden jetzt das stimmt schon das aktuelle powerpoint
ist nicht schlecht im vergleich zu den alten points ok was ist jetzt schon das ist ja easy
gewesen aber es steht natürlich sway nicht da drin starten mal neu sicher ist sicher
man weiß denn die was für dora das ist eine distribution von rett hat quasi die bastel
baustelle für für rett hat sway jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt wie das funktioniert
chrome sind dabei man firefox mal starten knoop terminal starten oder hat meine meine
tastatur setting schon mal nicht mitgenommen ok mal gucken ob copy paste geht ah guckt
hier mal ist das kap dann ist es dann ist das in zwei back kann das sein wenn hier noch
nicht mal wenn auch selbst unter dem aktuellen fedora die aber copy und paste funktioniert
habt ihr es gesehen copy und paste geht aber desktop switchen geht hier nicht das ist alles
ziemlich kaputt guck wenn ich hier in der in der menüleiste bin vom firefox geht das
switchen nicht und sowas das ist alles noch nicht so rund muss ich sagen das also wenn
das xorg ablösen soll und die hälfte nicht richtig funktioniert also ich da schwarz
zumindest copy paste funktioniert hier schon mal aber guck mal ich kann es nicht den desktop
switchen einfach weil ich hier in einem dialog drinne bin es ist schon fail das man hier
auch nicht richtig also schön ist das nicht auf art habe ich nicht ausprobiert ich habe
auch auf meinem manjaro normalerweise noch noch ganz normalen x drauf tja also wenn das
quasi unterm aktuellen fedora nicht funktioniert ich seit einer weile schon wehren haben und
das insgesamt eigentlich so mit am besten funktionieren sollte guck aber es ist hier
auf jeden fall viel besser der maus zeiger spack nicht so rum dass das das ist schon
fast benutzbar fast die menus gehen auch nicht mehr weg aber halt meine maus erkennt er
noch nicht was ziemlich nervig ist jetzt erkennt er so wenn man einmal da drin ist jetzt erkennt
er sie wieder nicht und das sieht auch auf jeden fall nicht richtig skaliert aus so ganz
richtig funktioniert das noch nicht und das skalieren sieht ja auch mal ultra hässlich
aus warum skaliert er das überhaupt so komisch hallo ist das was ist das für ein schwachsinn
warum skaliert er das bitteschön so der soll der soll der soll die ui elemente skalieren
und nicht einfach das fenster nur was immer im jahr 2000 2001 irgendwie hängen geblieben
was ui design angeht linux oder was hier los
installiert gewesen gut also unter fedora funktioniert auch nicht richtig was mich zum
fazit bringt für xorg und i3 wm in kombination gibt es auch keinen ordentlichen ersatz das
heißt ich werde auch wenn das neue ubuntu kommt weiter auf xorg bleiben vielleicht tut
der sway irgendwann mal oder steig auf mek um lull ist schon enttäuschend geht euer eine
sache probieren wir noch gehen dann jetzt hier trei eichens gehen der trei eichens
wir probieren das jetzt mal wir probieren mal trei eichens aus sway config
oh muss ich sagen das haben sie das haben sie ganz praktisch gemacht hier wenn kommando
nicht gefunden ist bietet er mir gleich anders zu installieren kann ich mit leben bin ich
praktisch
aber geil wenn es nicht funktioniert
hat
hat der scheiß mal irgendjemand überhaupt getestet bevor sie das release ich werde auch
hier keine paket abhängigkeit von hand irgendwie lösen muss immer denn
ist da was
ich verwende nie nano normalerweise aber wenn ich kann installieren darf aus irgendwelchen
gründen das schon bitter ich weiß schon warum ich angelux verwende da muss ich den
skram zwar selbst einrichten aber es funktioniert wie sucht man überhaupt in wm sorry wie sucht
man überhaupt in nano
hier wie ging das jetzt mit mit mit trei eichen trei wie war das ray output reimer reiner
so gucken wir mal ob trei eichens hier funktionieren
nö keine trei eichens
da benüßt die funktionieren immerhin
da mal wieder ein video kommen wenn ich bock habe auf youtube mal wieder was zu machen
probiere ich jetzt noch aus output copy paste geht jetzt ja oder auch nicht
jetzt so nicht keine trei eichens
wie hieß das ding ganz vergessen wieso
wie hieß denn der ganze kram clip it gibt es auf jeden fall
trei eichens gut gg also ich bin nicht überzeugt
was den baro meinst du ich habe es an der falschen stelle hingeschrieben nee oder glaube
ich nicht das gucke ich jetzt noch mal nach ansonsten war der test jetzt von neuer linux
desktop technologie nicht sonderlich erfolgreich
also ich meine da so sachen wie copy paste nicht richtig funktionieren menüs nicht
richtig funktionieren also das ist schon hart hart lächerlich
ich habe es an der falschen stelle gemacht stimmt
immer noch keine trei eichens
jetzt gucke ich noch mal ob das auch richtig war
was war ziemlich sicher war das trei output
noch mal so
guck mal sogar mein startmenü ist gerade abgeschmiert seht ihr es hier oben das ist fail das ist
echt das kann man noch nicht was zum nee keine menüs das ist wirklich nicht die zukunft
hier das ist nicht die zukunft
es ist auch so geil bei 4m wenn man kann die 4m löschen aber es ist im endeffekt noch
alles da man muss danach in den ordner gehen und noch mal löschen weil weiß nur 4m wäre
warum
dann war das jetzt ziemlich für n arsch ich weiß aber zumindest eine sache habe ich daraus
jetzt gelernt wenn das neue Ubuntu kommt werde ich garantieren nicht auf Wayland umsteigen
und auch nicht auf sway sondern ich werde bei x bleiben mit i3 und gut ist das funktioniert
einfach das funktioniert dann auch copy paste und trei eichens und ich kann fenster richtig
verschieben also na prozentual von bildschirm und sowas funktioniert einfach nee nähe
das hat mich echt nicht überzeugt moin x conner so jetzt bin ich fertig habe ich ausprobiert
wie lange habe ich jetzt gestreamt 2 stunden 6 ja flix kohler gibt es wayland als neuen
display server aber wie man gesehen hat jetzt funktioniert das ganze noch mehr schlecht
als recht also wenn das weiterhin so ist würde ich sagen auf absehnbare zeit wird da kein
wird da nix xorg ersetzen wenn man noch nicht mal fenster richtig wie seisen kann hallo
das war so viel fail in in in in jetzt einer einer sitzung hier das kann ich ja das weiß
ich gar nicht wie ich das noch irgendwie schön reden soll copy paste geht nicht fenster lassen
sich nicht re seisen menüs sind auf einmal weg fenster verschieben lassen sich nicht
ordentlich sway funktioniert nicht richtig also ich sehe mich da in nächster zeit nicht
von xorg und die drei woanders hin wechseln gut war eine spontane sache mit dem stream
heute was arkenas wieso hast du destiny 2 das kommt doch erst im oktober für pc ja
das ist die beta das ist noch die beta die könnte ich jetzt eigentlich mal installieren
den installieren wir das doch warum sind die neuen windows ui ist eigentlich so hässlich
aus aber das wird mit dem update im oktober besser ich freue mich auf das neue windows
update ich weiß nicht ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe alle leute sind ja super windows
updates in letzter zeit so scheiße dann geht es wieder nicht und update wieder eine stunde
und irgendwas geht in die hose ich freue mich auf das neue windows update weil zum ersten
mal es eine ordentliche moderne design design skip design richtlinien wie windows apps aussehen
sollen und quasi die die kompletten apps die dabei sind bei windows halt auch so angepasst
werden du hast dann nicht mehr quasi windows programme über drei generationen die alle
unterschiedlich aussehen mal eins mit ribbon bars einmal mit tech context menüs einmal
mit so einmal mit transparent im hintergrund einmal ohne sondern die werden alle angepasst
und es gibt dann auch eine ordentliche richtlinie wie windows programme aussehen sollen kann
euch das mal zeigen wie microsoft sich das vorstellt wobei das glaube ich so eine typische
marketing seite ist wo man nicht viel daran erkennt das ist das ist wieder so ein absolut
nicht sagende seite ja dann macht microsoft mal was was was was was gutes ja und die sehen
auch wirklich gut aus den neuen anwendungen dann hast du so eine absolut nichts sagende
wer interessiert sich für vor er anwendung das juckt doch keinen ja hier erkennt man
so halbweg na das ist auch nicht hier erkennt man es ganz gut haben die haben die irgendwie
ordentliche beispiele das ist auch so typisch microsoft in der heutigen zeit da muss man
einfach korrekt sein wenn man werbung macht dann braucht man dann braucht man den asiaten
da braucht man den schwarzen dann braucht man hier natürlich hier plon plon und weiß
und na jetzt fehlt bloß eigentlich noch mexikaner oder so das machen die gerne bei microsoft
das muss dann immer so schön repräsentativ für alle sein und der größte fail war weiß
gar nicht ob ihr das kennt da haben sie in den bild angepasst das war da hatten sie
in bild mit ich muss euch das mal zeigen weiß ja ob man das sieht microsoft marketing fail
das ist der politisch korrekte ausdruck jetzt für für schwarz darf man das sagen ja das
da und gibt es das gibt es das in groß das bild ja genau ich weiß ich ich suche mal
er fällt euch was auf an dem bild fällt euch was auf an dem bild fällt euch daran was auf
man außer dass es das gleiche bild ist und dass sie das hier der typ anders aussieht
aber fällt euch noch was auf das meine ich nicht also dass der typ hier ein anderer ist
klar aber fällt euch an dem typ was auf ich weiß nicht wie gut man das im stream erkennt
ich so mal ran was mal auf guckt euch mal die hand von dem typ an fällt euch da was
auf die haben die hand nicht ausgetauscht guckt mal man sieht ja dass es überhaupt
nicht passt marketing fail ich finde ich finde das an sich kann ich das verstehen ja dass
man dass man die leute hier drauf anpasst aber dass man halt hier nicht aufpasst mit
der hand das finde ich halt fail so aber erst mal zu der eigentlichen geschehen sache zurück
zu kommen wir gucken uns einmal bilder zu an irgendjemand hat kann im chat geschrieben
ist auch dringend nötig mit der mit der einheitlichen designrichtlinie ist es auch es gibt ein
video gucken ob man hier was gescheites drin sieht ja hier erkennt man es ein bisschen
hier erkennt man es ein bisschen dass das das ist nicht wirklich das ist keine richtige
transparenz zum beispiel also sprich das ist nicht so so einfach hintergrund genommen
und geplört sondern es sorgt tatsächlich dafür dass man immer noch guten kontrast
zum vordergrund hat aber es trotzdem so aussieht als würde der hintergrund durchschimmern
und sowas das ist richtig cool was die sich da ausgedacht haben das kommt halt mit dem
neuen windows update deswegen freue ich mich darauf das wird auch mal zeit weil ich meine
das kann doch nicht sein dass du auf dem aktuellen windows parallel sowas hier hast also mir
ist klar dass das eine paint ist und das andere der calculator und danach hast du noch sowas
so das sind quasi die anwendung designs aus jeweils einem eigenen jahrzehnt das ist 1990
das ist 2000 das ist 2010 also du hast quasi standardanwendungen die parallel bei windows
drin sind und alle drei überhaupt nicht mal sogar relativ beliebte beliebte anwendungen
sind hast du ein design 1990 2000 2010 und das darf es halt nicht sein guck man sieht
hier auch schon dass sie mir hier schimmert hinten einfach nur ganz normal blöhr durch
genau und dann hat dann da siehst du mit das das nächste weil es gerade einer geschrieben
systeme steuerung das nächste dilemma war es microsoft da siehst du bei der systemsteuerung
eigentlich wollte man destiny deinstallieren fällt mir nur gerade so ein wir machen das
gerade mal ok ja jetzt dass sie weg als das erste das dilemma was microsoft sieht man
auch an der systemsteuerung das ist das ist quasi die neue systemsteuerung und dann hat
man immer noch da hat man immer noch die hier die alte von 2000 so 2005 oder sowas man sieht
auch hier wieder komplett andere bedienung komplett anders aufgebaut und jetzt ist die
frage wo findet man was findet man es da drin findet man es darin warum kann ich programme
hier deinstallieren und hier deinstallieren warum wo ist das sinn hier kann ich die windows
firewall ausschalten hier kann ich die windows firewall ausschalten und hier kann ich die
windows firewall ausschalten aber manche sachen kann ich hier drin machen aber nicht hier
drin und manche hier drin und manche nicht hier drin dann fragt man sich was was geht
in den jungs vor aber ich finde das hier ist so das beste beispiel für wildwuchs unter
windows und einfach einfach fail der letzten 20 jahre sowas hat es bei apple nicht gegeben
auch wenn ich kein apple fan bin es kann nicht sein dass du quasi drei beliebte standard
anwendungen hast und alle drei mit komplett anderem bedienkonzept ja menus von 1990 so
2000 irgendwie bis 2005 rum hier hier ribbon oder sagen wir 2005 rum ribbon bar geschiss
und sonst was und jetzt hier das neueste halt dieses minimalistische metro zeugs da
ist ein hamburger menü übrigens das nennt sich hamburger menü wer das noch nicht gehört
hat weil das aussieht wie ein hamburger könnt ihr lachen das ding heißt wirklich hamburger
menü weiß auch nicht wem da langweilig war so und das erinnert microsoft jetzt und wir
können uns so kann man beispiel angucken gucken ob es hier ein gutes gut gute demo gab
ja hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut ja gut 3d juckt mich jetzt nicht das der feiert
sich nur ein bisschen ab die hatten ein ganz gutes ganz gutes demo video von von von ihrer
bildkonferenz das video mein ich übrigens oder mein ich das das ist ein microsoft auch
so so so so schwierig macht also es gab es gab ein video wo sie das neue design gezeigt
haben das da und das war richtig cool mit dieser mit dieser demo anwendung die sich
hier gezeigt haben ich muss es mal die letzte version davon angucken microsoft präsentation
ja also man sieht es hier schon dass es dass es hier im hintergrund durch schimmert aber
darauf geachtet wie das der kontrast dazu stimmt die dass die animation sinnvoll eingebaut
werden dass am quasi wartezeit nicht mehr so lang vorkommen sowas also da hat microsoft
wirklich gutes gebaut und sprich die anwendung werden dann hoffe ich alle angepasst die dabei
sind paint fliegt ja eh raus gibt es jetzt ja nur noch paint 3d was gar nicht aufgeht
weil kein bock und so gut jetzt habe ich mich auch noch mal dazu ausgelassen was ist denn
adobe vo co schon nie gehört sagt mir nichts jetzt
gut dann machen wir an der stelle jetzt schluss spontane sache ich hoffe
ich hat trotzdem gefallen ja wir sind schon fertig mit unbunt obeter hat nicht funktioniert
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe und dann sehen wir uns das nächste mal macht's gut
bis dahin tschüss